the trauma is something that leaves the  brain different going forward right so  it's not just anything negative that  happens because people say what about  post-trauma resilience well yes if we  Define trauma differently right  something that really hurts us inside  isn't something we're built to be  resilient to right something that  doesn't do that right that strikes us  his way oh that was negative we can  respond to with resilience right but  what you're talking about and how we're  framing this is though that like there's  a neurobiological anchoring to trauma in  that it overwhelms us and then we are  different going forward right and  nowhere is it written they're like oh  that only happens if you're in a  terrible accident or if a loved one dies  or if someone assaults you right those  brain changes can happen in other  situations as well we know that to be  true